just mentioned that his favorite
christmas song was white christmas i
hate to break it to him but if you're
dreaming of a white christmas you might
be a racist
of course
i'm talking about snow but america can't
escape the framework of skin color
because instead of spreading cheer enjoy
this holiday season
black lives matter is asking its
followers to participate in segregation
they call their mission black xmas and
its goal is pretty simple
fight quote white supremacist capitalism
now you're probably wondering
what is white supremacist capitalism and
that also
is simple it's any business owned by a
white person
so if you want to celebrate back black
xmas this year all you have to do is
stay away from those white supremacist
stores and spend money exclusively at
black owned businesses
while blm will call you a racist for
shopping at businesses not owned by
black people they have no problem
accepting millions of dollars in
donations from what they consider white
supremacists
after the death of george floyd
companies like apple amazon microsoft
google coca-cola
they lined up to give black lives matter
millions and blm
happily accepted in fact they raised
more than 90 million dollars in 2020
where it went to what purpose that money
went we're not too sure we know it
didn't go to help any black people
unless you count the co-founder of blm
who bought four mansions after her
non-profit raked in all that cash
so we've established that black lives
matter is full of hypocrites who will
take money from companies they consider
to be white supremacist while telling
their followers
to boycott them but how to apple amazon
microsoft google coca-cola how do they
feel about segregated shopping
well they've been silent so far
and look i can be logical i can follow
the left's rules silence well that's
complicity
the truth is black lives matter and
those that enable that radical group
have more in common with eugene bull
connor than they do martin luther king
you can never whip these birds
if you don't keep you and them separate
i found that out in blaming him
you've got to keep the white and the
black separate
you know returning to the segregated
lunch counter is ugly enough and every
moral american should shout it
down but there's even more to this story
because
black xmas is part of something much
larger and perhaps even more dangerous
democrats are now pushing something
called
racial equity audits coming soon to an
employer near you they're starting with
america's tech companies
it proposes these audits of fining
businesses twenty thousand dollars a day
if they refuse to comply comply with
what well they say
promoting racial justice but it actually
does the exact opposite here's how one
popular part of this audit calls for
abolishing the definition of merit so
they can quote attract black talent now
how is that it's as if black people
can't meet current standards
i know that's racist you know that's
racist we know that's blatantly racist
and so do they so why are they pushing
these audits
to take control of corporate america the
audits are usually performed by outside
groups with get this
close ties to democrats and george soros
so when they say they're looking to
promote diversity equity and inclusion
in reality they're using these audits to
move their operatives into top positions
and powerful tech companies in order to
do their bidding listen to the president
of a left-wing organization entitled
color of change rashad robinson he
testified in front of congress last week
and he called for quote independent
auditors to review
new products from tech companies before
they're released to the public this
gives auditors of course
carte blanche final say over technology
we are allowed to use
so are tech companies open to taking
orders from these radical groups it
seems so
the washington free beacon reports in
2018 color of change quote
successfully pushed facebook
into
completing an audit that called for more
restrictions on trump's post after the
audit was released
facebook then
hired an obama administration justice
department official to lead the
company's civil rights strategy
i just want to remind you this has
nothing to do with helping black people
or promoting racial equality so what is
their goal hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else